your good friend and and partner Jordan
Peele making movies oh yeah
and and I am curious because I heard you
say once in an interview that you were
actually afraid that he might cast you
in one of your movie in one of his
movies and I was thinking why why would
you be afraid of that it's just that the
terror the terror that he invokes in the
job itself I feel like I would be afraid
to even be in the genre yeah and the
other thing I'm afraid is he can be a
bit of a prankster I'm afraid that he
would like put spiders in the movie and
then I wouldn't be able to do that but I
but I love him so much I would still do
it
even though I am legitimately
arachnophobic is that is that so if you
what degree is it because some people
say they're afraid of spiders I don't
there are very few people who love like
oh goodie a spider but I wish it was
bigger but my question is how extreme is
it with you
the arachnophobia on its on a one to ten
scale it's like an eight point seven two
six yeah yeah so you can round it up to
a seven point three or eight point three
what did I just say but it's it's
legitimate it's legitimate but I would
like to say very successfully I had a
very very good experience of a couple
weeks ago there's a spider outside of my
home but it within the proximity of my
home it in the outside part of my home
right and I I got a baggie and I put
this we got the spider in the baggie I
was sweating copiously but we still got
him in there and then transported him to
another place so I did I did I did
interact with said spider that was
Meryl Streep Conan O'Brien spider
transmit yeah I was the least earned
high five put the spider block I have a
son yeah my son will come to me to be
like spider and on my bathroom I will
running and he'll make it sound like I
need a rake you like or a harpoon or
spoon get out there and like you need a
jewellers
[Laughter]